même en ces jours de déménagement pour
laetitia perez
elle quitte son condo à saint-hubert
pour une maison unifamiliale à
saint-constant son déménagement
elle a pris soin de bien le planifier je
les fais ça fait longtemps que je les
fais depuis mai dans la seconde
laetitia devait aussi se conformer à des
règles d'hygiène strictes
j'ai reçu un papier vraiment d'aider la
ville d aussi les syndicats ici les deux
condos ils nous ont envoyés des
concernés pour les nettoyer toutes les
surfaces dans son condo aidé par sa mère
et nettoie tous deux fois plus qu'une en
restant à une distance de 2 mètres des
déménageurs obligé également de
respecter les mesures sanitaires
c'est très difficile à respirer mais on
doit se protéger
port de masques et de gants des
infections du camion avant et après le
déménagement sont le b à ba du
déménageur qui doit protéger ses clients
en s'assurant que ces employés ne sont
pas à risque
chaque matin je le donne je les donne
une main et un formulaire qu'il met la
chine qu'il est qu'ils n'ont pas de
symptômes qu'ils sont danger - santé qui
s'est toujours la bonne foi de chaque
personne
laëtitia n'a négligé aucun détail c'est
là le secret pour réussir son
déménagement en temps de pandémie
alors c'est plus une question de le
planifier de penser notre affaire avant
avant de le faire à chaque étape et le
lavage des mains demeurent une
précaution de choix laetitia fait appel
à une entreprise mais la tradition du
déménagement veut que souvent ce soit
les amis qui prêtent main forte
les retrouvailles après la période de
confinement pourrait faire craindre un
relâchement
le relâchement est possible partout dans
tous les scénarios dans tout ce qu'on
fait présentement six et des ennemis qui
déménage on n'est pas obligé d'être
rapprochés d'eux habituellement la
saison du déménagement touche à sa fin à
la mi juillet mais cette année en raison
de lakovic 19
les entreprises voient leur carnet de
commandes s'étirait jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'août et six as milk radio canada
montréal